tom daley i like this part of the year
after an olympics because we get
olympians with medals and uh tom delhi
now is a gold medal
[Applause]
now
it
it looks a bit like christmas morning on
the table beside you
what have we got tom oh we've got a
whole selection i've got a whole
catalogue of things
first up i feel like i'm on like a tv
like sales show right qvc yeah so we've
got my knitted pouch which then has
inside
[Applause]
that's fun so there we are
that's very good i've got to chug it on
the floor
be all right yeah you know what i'll
nick them yeah
some crocheted
swim trunks
now can i just stop you there
i'm not gonna put them on no but they're
also they're not i mean cause if you get
them wet they are gonna retain a lot of
water
a lot of moisture yeah it's not it's not
something i would probably wear
it was actually something one of my
first projects that i made on a training
camp and i dare and get them wet because
if you get wool wet i mean you know how
it goes if you try and wash any knitwear
yes it's like you know they they shrink
quite considerably so you wouldn't
really want to wear them into the pool
no and your talks can't get any smaller
tom so uh i don't want anything falling
out oh we've got you've been through is
that the famous cardigan this is the
cardigan that i made at the olympics
to commemorate my
olympics
it's got like ignore the inside because
the inside's the wrong side but yeah
it's got like a bit of a it was a team
tb jumper for me to remember my tokyo
olympics looks like you were in tokyo
for about six months
there was a lot of spare time
[Music]
you